aquí tenemos dos variables aleatorias
diferentes y lo que queremos hacer es
encontrar qué tipo de variables
aleatorias son la variable aleatoria x
es igual al número de seysses después de
12 tiros de un dado sin cargar esto luce
como una variable aleatoria binomial de
hecho estoy segura de que es una
variable aleatoria binomial veamos si
cumple con todas las condiciones el
resultado de la ejecución es éxito o
fracaso
y los resultados de cada ejecución son
independientes entre sí el que obtenga
un 6 en la tercera ejecución es
independiente de que obtenga un 6 en la
primera o la segunda ejecución esta es
una condición importante tenemos un
número fijo de ejecuciones en este caso
vamos a tener 12 ejecuciones y la última
condición es que cada ejecución tiene la
misma probabilidad de éxito en efecto
esta variable cumple todas las
condiciones para hacer una variable
aleatoria binomial este es solo un
repaso de conceptos que hemos visto en
otros vídeos y que hay de esta variable
aleatoria y el número de tiros hasta
obtener 16 con un dado sin cargar esta
variable parece diferente veamos cuáles
son las diferencias se cumple la
condición de que el resultado de la
ejecución es éxito o fracaso bueno cada
tiro va a tener un resultado y será
exitoso cuando el resultado sea un 6 así
que el resultado de cada ejecución puede
calificarse como éxito o fracaso si
cumple con esta primera condición los
resultados de cada ejecución son
independientes
no importa si sale un 6 en la primera o
tercera o cuarta ejecución el resultado
es independiente de si obtuve un 6 o no
en una ejecución anterior se cumple esta
segunda condición y también cada
ejecución tiene la misma probabilidad
cada ejecución tiene un sexto de
probabilidad de que salga un 6 así que
se cumple con esta otra condición no
mencioné esta tercera condición por una
razón y es que evidentemente no tenemos
un número fijo de ejecuciones en este
caso podemos tirar el dado unas 50 veces
antes de que caiga un 6 aunque el hacer
50 ejecuciones antes de que salga un 6
es algo poco probable el punto es que no
tenemos un número fijo de ejecuciones
antes de que salga un 6
de hecho pensemos en cuál es el valor
mínimo y el valor máximo de y el valor
mínimo que puede tener esta variable
aleatoria allí es igual a un tiro si
tuviéramos un 6 como resultado de la
primera ejecución pero cuál será el
valor máximo para esta variable
aleatoria piensen un poco en ello
suponiendo que ya lo pensaron la real
es que no tenemos un valor máximo
determinado para esta variable no
podemos decir de antemano un número
máximo de ejecuciones porque siempre
estará la probabilidad por pequeña que
sea de que se requieran más ejecuciones
para obtener un 6 este tipo de variable
aleatoria que cumple con varias de las
condiciones de una variable aleatoria
binomial como que el resultado de cada
ejecución pueda ser éxito o fracaso
también que los resultados de las
ejecuciones son independientes y que
cada ejecución tenga la misma
probabilidad pero no tenemos un número
fijo de ejecuciones es decir cuando
tenemos que ver cuántas ejecuciones se
necesitan para tener cierto resultado
exitoso es un indicador de que tenemos
este tipo de variable aleatoria un buen
indicador para identificar las variables
aleatorias binomial es es cuando nos
preguntan cuántos son los resultados
exitosos en un número fijo de
ejecuciones así que si cumplimos con
todas estas condiciones sabemos que
tenemos una variable aleatoria binomial
pero cuando se cumple con que el
resultado de cada ejecución
o fracaso que los resultados de las
ejecuciones sean independientes y que
cada ejecución tenga la misma
probabilidad pero no se cumple el número
de éxitos en un número fijo de
ejecuciones y en su lugar nos interesa
conocer cuántas ejecuciones se
realizaron hasta tener una ejecución
exitosa entonces tenemos una variable
aleatoria geométrica en próximos vídeos
veremos con más detalle por qué se le
llama geométrica a este tipo de
variables pero les puedo decir que se
debe a que las matemáticas involucradas
en las probabilidades de los diversos
resultados se parecen mucho al
crecimiento geométrico oa las secuencias
y series geométricas que hemos visto en
otro tipo de vídeos y en caso de que se
me haya olvidado mencionarlo la razón
por la que a estas variables se les
llama binomial es es porque si pensamos
en las probabilidades de los resultados
tenemos los llamados coeficientes
binomial es que surgen en combinatoria
esas cosas a su vez vienen de los
triángulos de pascal cuando tomamos un
binomio y lo elevamos a potencias que
siempre se están incrementando de ahí
en estos términos en los siguientes
vídeos nos enfocaremos en cómo reconocer
la diferencia entre estos tipos de
variables y luego veremos cómo trabajar
con variables aleatorias geométricas y
con esto terminamos